going for a walk with her grandson just
a year ago goo ba ha jelly lava wouldn't
have dreamed it was possible at the time
she was in China in one of the
internment camps for weakest or
education centers as the leadership in
Beijing calls them this is from the day
I was arrested it states my name my
birth date and that I am a terrorist goo
ba house says the Chinese authorities
never explained why they thought she was
a terrorist she tells us about the cruel
conditions in the camps about torture
and humiliation you were caught speaking
Weger you were locked up in a dark room
we also had to write out lines of praise
to the Chinese Communist Party every 10
days we had to stick our arms through to
get an injection we didn't know what it
was but the younger women stopped having
their periods we had to do sit-ups in
the nude it didn't matter if you were 14
or 84 that's how they violated our honor
Istanbul is home to around 25,000 we
gus' for example there's 18 bono
district like guru Baha many have found
refuge here some even say that the
capital of the weakest is no longer in
Xinjiang but in Turkey in primary school
the children of those who fled China
singing reading writing in their mother
tongue the teachers here say in China
that would be impossible
many Weger say that ethnic and religious
ties with Turkey have made building new
lives here in Istanbul easier for them
at first glance this neighborhood
appears lively bustling but the
community has an open secret almost
everybody here they say has a relative
or friend who has disappeared into one
of the camps in China talk of my
brother's were imprisoned my sister was
sent to account did they get out are
they dead or alive I don't know I
haven't had any contact with my family
in five or six years not even a phone
call I'm 99% sure that they're in the
camps or in prison I haven't heard from
my family in to five years dozens of
versions of the same story
for some it's too painful to talk
China's ambassador to Turkey admits that
some we girls have trouble contacting
their families
he says steps are being taken but he
rejects reports of human rights
violations in chang-jung the education
centers are not prisons they are not
concentration camps as some media
reports say in fact these places are
more like boarding schools and the basic
human rights of the students are
respected they can contact their
families and receive visitors I have the
impression that some media and powers
are abusing this subject to cast China's
Xinjiang policy in a bad light
salsa guru Baha Jayla lova sees things
very differently she would like foreign
countries to put more pressure on China
she says the horrors she experienced in
the camps of ching-chong have changed
her and she's speaking up in the hope
that others espera fate